If you are rich or if you are super
rich, you have a nice life, right? You
know, I've seen how you guys live and I
know you know how you live, right? It's
nice. You know, you guys get a lot of
luxury and it's cool. Um, by pushing
this further and further and further and
taking more and more and more, you are
aggressively destabilizing the economies
and political systems of the countries
which you live in and which give you
extreme luxury.
What the are you doing?
It's enough. It's enough. And you know,
you have we have these stories in
history. I don't know how true they are,
that you know, when the British elites
got so rich, they eventually decided to
do things like more philanthropy and,
you know, help set up the welfare state
and help protect the poor. And for that
reason, you know, they were able to
protect the political stability of the
countries they lived in. Whereas the
French elites, they didn't give anything
back. They did all their let them eat
cake and they get their heads chopped
off. Look, I ain't trying to cut
nobody's heads off.
You've got enough. If you keep pushing,
you will destabilize the countries that
give you these enormous amounts of
wealth. Look at what happened in
history. Look at what happened in the
20th century. I'm not trying to
redistribute wealth away from the rich.
I am trying to stop the redistribution
that is bankrupting ordinary people.
Listen, I'm out here with my white flag
up. I would accept a peace treaty. Let's
stop it now. If you keep pushing under
this system where you don't pay tax and
the poor pay tax and you increasingly
take everything and bankrupt everybody
else, you will destroy the political
stabilities of this country.